merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur depuis que je suis ministre de
l'Intérieur je ne de cesse de rappeler
aux Français que la menace terroriste et
singulièrement la menace terroriste
islamiste est extrêmement
importante 43 attentats islamistes
déjoués par les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur un tous les mois et
demi 1500 personnes interpellées qui ont
un lien direct avec de l'apologie du
terrorisme des préparations d'attentat
depuis 5 ans 6500 personnes par an que
nous mettons sous technique de
renseignement expulsion des 922 fichiers
s irrég du territoire national il y en
avait 1142 voilà 5 ans
489 aujourd'hui encore sur le territoire
national en plus de la moitié sont en
prison et l'autre moitié sont soit en
centre de rétention administratif soit
signé résidence soit en effet en
contentieux juridique et j'espère que la
loi immigration nous permettra d'aller
plus vite plus fort et plus ferme et en
effet monsieur le sénateur s'il n'y a
pas de menace organisée exogène à notre
connaissance la menace organisé exogène
du fait de la situation au Sahel du fait
de la situation au Proche-Orient du fait
de la situation en Afghanistan au levent
nous fait penser qu'en Europe il se peut
que ces cellules se reconstituent mais
la menace principale vous savez c'est
une menace endogène une ubérisation
pardon de ce mot du terrorisme qui
attend la publication des caricatures
des soi-disants blasphèmes des
soi-disants difficultés qui toucheraient
le monde particulier pour lequel il
seraient attachés dans leur
fantasmogorie des complots sur Internet
qui
peut-être permet de passer à l'acte
parce qu'un diodisme d'atmosphère existe
du fait malheureusement d'un écosystème
islamiste que nous devons combattre et
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement par la
loi séparatisme par les lois terrorisme
par le courage de servic de
renseignement combat donc oui monsieur
le sénateur s'il n'y a pas de menace
caractérisé et organisé du fait même des
événements dramatiques et des des
attaques terroristes islamistes contre
Israël il est évident que le climat
n'est pas positif et que la menace est
très forte et je veux particulièrement
avoir une pensée bien sûr aussi pour nos
compatriotes de confessions juives qui
ont peur et pour lequel la République
les protège chaque jour et chaque nuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]